imagine that you could buy stocks in
your uncle's farm and yes I know that
assumes that your uncle has a farm let's
say it's a small farm it's got some cows
etc and you can buy stocks from his
company and this is something you would
do on the stock market just like you do
with big companies like Apple Exxon or
Chevron think I'm crazy well actually
I'm not at all and at the end of this
video you're gonna see exactly where I'm
coming from
[Applause]
let's say you want to start a company a
traditional company let's stick to the
example of California it's going to
produce milk and other dairy products
what is the first thing that you need
well of course that's gonna be money you
need money to buy the property the
facilities as well as the all-important
cows
so where can you get the money to do
this well the first option of course is
gonna be to go to the bank but this has
a whole bunch of issues the first one is
that if it wasn't risky enough to start
your own company having a loan makes it
even more risky you can end up bankrupt
since in debt
besides then there's the whole thing
that the banker might actually not give
you that loan if you ever tried to get a
loan to start a company you know exactly
what I'm talking about it's pretty hard
to convince a banker to lend you any
money so let's first of all disregard of
a bank option the next alternative is a
venture capitalist you know those guys
out in Silicon Valley these are people
with loads of cash and a willingness to
invest in young talents just like you I
mean who knows maybe a small farm might
become the next industry being off
but then he runs the problem that you
probably don't know any venture
capitalists especially if you're
somewhere like in the middle of India so
there's no blanks there's no venture
capitalists but maybe a parents are rich
but if they're not well I guess that's
not any help so just to hold on for a
minute because I think I have an idea
what if you could already enter the
stock market you know something like
Wall Street where General Motors and
McDonald's operate the good thing
another stock market is that you don't
need to know a millionaire to get
funding there are thousands of small
investors out there who buy stocks every
day so let's say you divide your company
into ten thousand stocks and each of
them has an initial price of $10 and
people no matter where they live can buy
those shares so maybe there's a guy in
Kansas who buys one stock and there's a
woman in France who buys 10 this way
with no contacts and no bank loans you
can get the funding you need you just
need a good idea and a bit of hard work
right
well hold on a second doing it too
excited there's a pretty major problem
here for instance if you want to get
into the New York Stock Exchange your
company should have already made at
least 10 million dollars in the last
three years and that's just the
beginning
there are lots and lots of regulations
that you have to meet well this is the
situation that the guys from Huckle skya
agricultural company were in they lived
in Russia and they wanted to start a cow
farm and they had no money so well what
do you think they did well check this
out
russian-backed Koko's kya agricultural
company plans to launch an ICO named
milk coin to fund a dairy farm yeah you
heard that right these farmers launch
their own cryptocurrency it's basically
their own version of Bitcoin they
advertised it on their website and
launched the offer of these new coins
this is what we call an initial coin
offering or I see oh so now you might be
wondering well why would I buy another
cryptocurrency there's a Bitcoin enough
now you might just think that you're
just buying some sort of virtual coin
here but the reality is you're actually
buying stocks and you're doing it
without going through the traditional
stock markets at the end of this video
I'm gonna tell you what happens with
this company but the fact is they're not
the only example only 48% of icos were
successful last year but startups still
managed to raise 5.6 billion dollars yes
if you have appears to be a brand new
way of getting money to start a company
and it's available for everybody right
now but hold on just a minute because
not everything is so beautiful as you
can imagine these icy OHS seem like a
scammers paradise so the question is can
we really trust this brand new way of
starting companies and what does
Switzerland have to do with all of this
today were going to answer all of these
questions but before we do as usual
let's take a look back at the history
coins versus tokens in the year 2013
everyone in the tech industry was
already pretty aware of Bitcoin in
Silicon Valley they were celebrating all
kinds of events and talking about the
future of this currency
[Music]
in one of them there was a man called
j.r Willett this man had a very funny
idea he said we could create alternative
currencies that using the same
technology as Bitcoin would have
different rules and how are you gonna
pay all the itv but he would design all
of this they asked him and he said that
instead of looking for a venture
capitalist he could sell some notes what
we call a token that would be exchanged
for coins once they were created and
this is how the first initial coin
offering was created
[Music]
but before we continue many of you might
now be wondering well what exactly is a
token
well tokens are any elements that can be
changed in a blockchain cryptocurrencies
are one kind of token but there are many
more on the one hand we have those that
give a right to its owner for instance
those nodes that you could exchange for
brand new currencies when they are
created on the other hand we have the
tokens that are based on an asset this
would be the case of the stocks of the
Russian farmers having one of their
tokens means having a share of their
company this initial public offering of
tokens became fashionable in the year
2014 so why was that what exactly
happens in this year well that was the
year when the second most famous
cryptocurrency was created
atheria the decentralized platform that
might displace today's institutions
unlike Bitcoin we all know who is behind
aetherium this is a company that offers
way more than a cryptocurrency they also
offer a system so other people can
create their own cryptocurrencies and
their own tokens for example do you
remember this other video where I told
you about how a Spanish bank is using
blockchain to give corporate loans
well aetherium is the platform that they
use we are only talking about Spanish
banks here aetherium has made it really
easy for lots of people to start
creating different financial products on
blockchain the etherium rush has been
unleashed I SEOs are in fashion in the
tech investment world since then lots of
companies are getting financed this way
for example syrian labs a swiss company
that is about to launch their own
smartphone this company has got more
than a hundred and eighteen million
dollars thanks to one of the most
successful ICS in history and of course
there are all kinds of internet
companies that have been born with this
system but just hold on a second because
not everything is so great i cos they've
got no regulation whatsoever so you can
certainly imagine there are some
problems how to create an ICO scam in
five simple steps when I you might be
wondering well what's the difference
between an ICO and a website like
Kickstarter well that's actually pretty
easy to answer if you support some
Kickstarter project you can't sell any
shares on an ICO
you can buy a token or a coin and if it
rises higher in market value you can
sell it to another investor
the only problem is that here there is
no financial police or FCC running
against the bad guys so yes there were
plenty of people who thought they could
get rich really quick and then ended up
losing a ton of money for example save
Droid was a German company that wanted
to make a cryptocurrency based credit
card it had all the buzz words to make
speculators happy and everything seemed
great the technology was there and it
was very disruptive they got 50 million
dollars to launch it so once they got
their money what do you think happens
well they just disappeared and since
there was no public register whatsoever
it's almost impossible to find the owner
I'm sure you've all seen the ads online
for coins and tokens and things that
promise a whole ton of profit I mean for
a better understanding even the CEO of
etherium vitalik butterin recognized
that most of the IC o--'s are scams as
you can imagine governments have already
started to act China has banned ICS
America seems to be following a similar
path other countries like Estonia said
that it's okay to invest in IC O's for
everyone except Estonian citizens so
they're essentially saying something
like oh yeah man you could totally scam
anyone you like just not my own citizens
cool nonetheless there is one country
that has found an intermediate solution
they won't ban I SEOs but they will not
let them go unregulated as they are
today and what country am I talking
about well let me give you a clue it's
probably the channel we've talked most
about here on visual politic already
knows well yes of course we're talking
about
[Music]
[Applause]
Switzerland the crypto nation during
that video we made about Switzerland's
there we talked about Canton called Zog
which has the lowest taxes in the
country
[Music]
so well guess where etherium has its
headquarters having the biggest
cryptocurrency company in your country
means that you also have the biggest
experts on the matter there so most of
the IC OS are done on Swiss servers and
of course the Swiss government soon
realized that with or without scams this
was a multi-million dollar industry
[Music]
[Applause]
Switzerland wants to be the world
capital of cryptocurrency four of the 10
biggest initial coin offerings last year
were in Switzerland more than any other
country this is why some Swiss
municipalities let their citizens pay
taxes or even fines with crypto
currencies Zog having less than 30,000
inhabitants is already the home of 400
blockchain based companies and their
regional governments is already doing
trials to use this technology to
organize referendums you probably
already know that referendums and direct
democracy are essential in the Swiss
political system so well now they want
to do is blockchain and of course
Switzerland wants to become the pioneer
in ICO regulations too
[Applause]
Swiss financial authority releases ICO
specific regulatory guidelines for
example any company that wants to make
an ICO in Switzerland will have to do it
through a Swiss company this means they
will have to register then have to give
their name and physical address this way
it will be easier to chase terrorists
narcos or scanners as you can imagine
these regulations well they're starting
to work and many companies have already
gone to other tax havens like the Cayman
Islands which offer a complete
dog-eat-dog environments where you can
essentially do whatever you want this is
the short-term price you have to pay in
order to have a stable environment we're
talking about a world that still needs a
lot of work before it becomes a mature
market one thing is for sure it has
plenty of possibilities many scams lots
of money laundering and some easy money
to be made so the Swiss Way seems to be
the smartest so far yes and you
technology has come it is risky but it
has many possibilities too instead of
banning us or letting it run completely
free the best option is to regulate it
this way we take the good and avoid the
bad by the way going all the way back to
our Russian friends the ones you wanted
to finance their farm with
cryptocurrency well I've got some bad
news for you
[Music]
unfortunately since milk coin raised
only 2% of the soft cap we're giving
back all funds that we received we will
start the return on the 21st of November
huge thanks to our backers now the
question becomes do you think other
countries will follow the Swiss example
it is clear that we still need more time
for the ICO market to grow and become
mature but do you think it can be the
capitalist revolution that will open the
entry barriers to starting a company
please well leave your answer in the
comments section below and do visit our
friends from reconsider media the
podcast that provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and don't
forget that we publish brand new videos
like this one every week so hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon so
you don't miss any posts and if you want
you can support us on patreon and as
always I'll see you next time and if you
want to learn more about politics and
hear even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider media we have
a podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you then
[Music]